a rehearsal of the chaos that could be
coming to ukraine
protesters pretending to be
russia-backed separatists take to the
street
then take over a government building
beaten back by the security forces
a performance watched by their president
himself a former actor
mr president do you believe that there
will be a new russian invasion of
ukraine
this week and are you preparing for
russian air strikes on kiev
um
but a massive russian military build-up
around ukraine is no secret
here a naval drill off the coast of
crimea just a few miles away any
military attack would almost certainly
come with internal provocations too
which explains this training it's what
happened in 2014 when russia annexed
crimea and backed separatists in the
east
ukraine desperate to stop a repeat
with the us warning that a new russian
invasion of ukraine could happen any day
this might be one of the last chances
for ukrainian forces to get prepared for
the worst but plenty of people here
don't think an escalation is coming we
are not moving the aggression will not
happen and we are we are ready for that
and
but in our opinion it will not happen
yet ukraine's armed forces are getting
ready in case it does
[Music]
not
down the road another exercise to defend
a dam from more mock rioters
critical infrastructure a prime target
in any russian attack
crisis averted but this was just a
practice for a test they hope not to
face
but may well have to
debra haines sky news in herson region
southern ukraine